N
APPRECIATE IT. AER
MICHAEL COHEN CHECK. UH
MENTIONEDACCHECKING A
MOME AGO IN THE ER
PRESIDENT'S
TONIGHT, HE REPEATED A WHOLES AT
WHAT DID YOU WANTTO T I W A TRH
F FALSE
CLAIMS.WHICHBLE CALLING LIES BAU
THEY BEP HE KEGIL OF
T NOBODY HAD AHANISTANT WAS ACTN
H COR OF STATE BRAD
EN. UNTIL MONTHS
PEOPLE DEM
RIGHT AWAY THAT VERY WEAON I FN,
PARTICULARLY PARTI
DISHON WHEN  PIVOT
INTO HISEDERAL INVESTIGA
N THATNTLIHE
UPPOSEDGOTIAT WITH OW THES AND S
THIS A RADICAL LEFTIN ORGANIZATN
FLAGSN OFEDS D
TRIGGERING.
S WHATEAL
WIH THAT HASABSOLUTELY NOTHINGDX
AND MOSTLY CLOAND OTHER
TH H W
PRESEN DONEE. JIMMY CARTER'S
DONENA RGAEVERYBODY'S. I WASKING
WI NARVEELUNIDEE
SEPARATE CTHIS ISRIF
NONSENSE. NONE OF T TE
TT THE
PRD TO NEGOTIATE OVER THE RETURN
DOME FAL
. IT SAYS THAT THE OFT
ARIVF THE
TAS
THAT OBAMA BUSH BUSH THE BUSHHEM
TOOKS LIKE HE DEE BY THE NATIED
THAT LAW IMMEDIA UPO
THOSE PRESIDENTS, LEAVINROW ITSM
NRO MANAGED
FACILITIES. SO NOT LIKE THEIR
CLUR WHERE
THPRESIDENTIAL LIBRARIES
WOULD BELTN THE
ULLY THEIR.G FOR MORE THANO GETS
E
THE DOC OF JUSTICE TOO
OVER AND ISSUED
SO VESSS. BUISAS WHEDHE SAME
ELON THAT HE HAS TALKED
BEFORE THE CLA,BEFORE ABOUT
VOTES. YEAH. THE ILLEG STUFFED T
WHAT MOREAN WEAY ABOUT THIS?OT T
WE'VE BEEN WITHSYEARS NOW. IT D
TRP' TOP OFFICIALS FRAUDTHE COUN
CHHE OERLFFICIAVEOT